The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIC GRIMSON: Ladies
and gentlemen, I'd
like to get started.
My name's Eric Grimson.
I have the privilege of
serving as MIT'S chancellor
for academic advancement, you
can go look up what that means,
and like John I'm a
former head of course six.
This term, with
Ana and John, I'm
going to be splitting the
lectures, so I'm up to date.
OK last time Ana introduced
the first of the compound data
types, tuples and lists.
She showed lots of ways
of manipulating them,
lots of built in things for
manipulating those structures.
And the key difference
between the two of them
was that tuples were immutable,
meaning you could not
change them, lists
were mutable, they
could be changed, or mutated.
And that led to both some nice
power and some opportunities
for challenges.
And, in particular, she showed
you things like aliasing,
where you could have two names
pointing to the same list
structure, and
because of that, you
could change the
contents of one,
it would change the appearance
of the contents of the other,
and that leads to
some nice challenges.
So the side effects
of mutability
are one of the things you're
going to see, both as a plus
and minus, as we go
through the course.
Today we're going to take
a different direction
for a little while, we're
going to talk about recursion.
It Is a powerful
and wonderful tool
for solving
computational problems.
We're then going to look at
another kind of compound data
structure, a dictionary,
which is also mutable.
And then we're going to put the
two pieces together and show
how together they actually
give you a lot of power
for solving some really neat
problems very effectively.
But I want to start
with recursion.
Perhaps one of the most
mysterious, at least according
to programmer's, concepts in
computer science, one that
leads to lots of really
bad computer science jokes,
actually all computer
science jokes are bad,
but these are particularly bad.
So let's start with the obvious
question, what is recursion?
If you go to the ultimate
source of knowledge, Wikipedia,
you get something that
says, in essence, recursion
is the process of repeating
items in a self-similar way.
Well that's really
helpful, right?
But we're going to see that
idea because recursion,
as we're going to
see in a second,
is the idea of taking a problem
and reducing it to a smaller
version of the same
problem, and using that idea
to actually tackle a bunch of
really interesting problems.
But recursion gets used
in a lot of places.
So it's this idea of
using, or repeating,
the idea multiple times.
So wouldn't it be great if your
3D printer printed 3D printers?
And you could just keep
doing that all the way along.
Or one that's a
little more common,
it's actually got
a wonderful name,
it's called mise en abyme,
in art, sometimes referred
to as the Droste
effect, pictures
that have inside them a
picture of the picture, which
has inside them a picture of the
picture, and you get the idea.
And of course, one
of the things you
want to think about
in recursion is not
to have it go on infinitely.
And yes there are even light
bulb jokes about recursion,
if you can't read
it, it says, how many
twists does it take to
screw in a light bulb?
And it says, if it's already
screwed in, the answer is 0.
Otherwise, twist it once, ask
me again, add 1 to my answer.
And that's actually a nice
description of recursion.
So let's look at
it more seriously.
What is recursion?
I want to describe it both
abstractly, or algorithmically,
and semantically or, if you
like, in terms of programming.
Abstractly, this is a
great instance of something
often called divide-and-conquer,
or sometimes called
decrease-and-conquer.
And the idea of
recursion is, I want
to take a problem I'm trying
to solve and say, how could I
reduce it to a simpler
version of the same problem,
plus some things
I know how to do?
And then that
simpler version, I'm
going to reduce
it again and keep
doing that until I get
down to a simple case
that I can solve directly.
That is how we're going to
think about designing solutions
to problems.
Semantically, this is typically
going to lead to the case
where a program, a
definition of function,
will refer to
itself in its body.
It will call itself
inside its body.
Now, if you remember your
high school geometry teacher,
she probably would wrap your
knuckles, which you're not
allowed to do, because
in things like geometry
you can't define something
in terms of itself, right?
That's not allowed.
In recursion, this is OK.
Our definition of a procedure
can in its body call itself,
so long as I have what
I call a base case,
a way of stopping that
unwinding of the problems,
when I get to something
I can solve directly.
And so what we're going to do
is avoid infinite recursion
by ensuring that we have
at least one or more base
cases that are easy to solve.
And then the basic
idea is I just
want to solve the same
problem on some simpler
input with the idea
of using that solution
to solve the larger problem.
OK, let's look at an
example, and to set
the stage I'm going to go back
to something you've been doing,
iterative algorithms.
For loops, while
loops, they naturally
lead to what we would
call iterative algorithms,
and these algorithms
can be described
as being captured by a
set of state variables,
meaning one or more variables
that tell us exactly
the state of the computation.
That's a lot of words,
let's look at an example.
I know it's trivial,
but bear with me.
Suppose I want to do
integer multiplication,
multiply two integers
together, and all
I have available
to me is addition.
So a times b is the same as
adding a to itself b times.
If I'm thinking about
this iteratively,
I could capture this computation
with two state variables.
One we'd just call
the iteration number,
and it would be
something, for example,
that starts at b, and each time
through the loop reduces 1.
One.
And it will keep doing that
until I've counted down
b times, and I get down to 0.
And at the same
time, I would have
some value of the
computation, I might call it
result, which starts at 0,
first time through adds an a,
next time through
adds an a, and it just
keeps track of how
many things have
I added up, until I get done.
And yeah, I know you
could just do mult,
but this is trying
to get this idea
of, how would I do
this iteratively.
So I might start off with i,
saying there are b things still
to add, and the result is 1.
The first time through the
loop, I add an a, reduce i by 1.
Next time through the
loop, I add in another a,
reduce i by 1, and
you get the idea.
I just walk down it
until, eventually, I got
to the end of this computation.
So we could write code
for this, and, actually,
it should be pretty
straightforward.
There it is.
Going to call it mult_iter,
takes in two arguments a and b,
and I'm going to capture
exactly that process.
So notice what I
do, I set up result
internally as just
a little variable
I'm going to use to
accumulate things.
And then, there
is the iteration,
as long as b is greater
than 0 what do I do?
Add a to result, store
it away, reduce b by 1,
and I'll keep doing
that until b gets
down to being equal
to 0, in which case
I just return the result.
OK, simple solution.
Now, let's think about
this a different way.
A times b is just adding
a to itself b times,
and that's the same as a
plus adding a to a itself
b minus 1 times.
OK, that sounds
like leisure to me,
that sounds like just
playing with words.
But it's really important,
because what is this?
Ah, that's just a
times b minus 1,
by the definition
of the top point.
And I know you're
totally impressed,
but this is actually really
cool, because what have I done?
I've taken one problem,
this one up here,
and I've reduced it to a simpler
version of the same problem,
plus some things
I know how to do.
And how would I solve this?
Same trick, that's a
times a times b minus 2,
I would just unwrap
it one more time,
and I would just keep
doing that until I get down
to something I can solve
directly, a base case.
And that's easy, when b equal
to 1, the answer is just a.
Or I could do when b is equal
to 0 the answer is just 0.
And there's code
to capture that.
Different form, wonderful
compact description,
what does it say?
It says, if I'm at the base
case, if b is equal to 1,
the answer is just a.
Otherwise, I'm going to solve
the same problem with a smaller
version and add it to a
and return that result.
And that's nice, crisp
characterization of a problem.
Recursive definition that
reduces a problem to a simpler
version of the same problem.
OK, let's look at
another example.
Classic problem in recursion
is to compute factorial,
right? n factorial,
or n bang if you
like, n exclamation point
is n times n minus 1,
all the way down to 1.
So it's the product of
all the integers from 1
up to n assuming n is
a positive integer.
So we can ask the
same question if I
wanted to solve this recursively
what would the base case be?
Well, when n is equal
to 1, it's just 1.
In the recursive case,
will n times n minus 1
all the way down to 1,
that's the same as n times
n minus 1 factorial.
So I can easily write
out the base case,
and I've got a nice recursive
solution to this problem.
OK, if you're like me and
this is the first time you've
seen it, it feels like
I've taken your head
and twisted it
about 180 degrees.
I'm going to take it another
180 degrees because you might
be saying, well,
wait a minute, how
do you know it really stops.
How do you know it really
terminates the computation?
So let's look at it.
There is my definition for
fact, short for factorial.
Fact of 1 is, if n is
equal to 1 return 1,
otherwise return n
times fact of n minus 1.
And let's use the tools
that Ana talked about,
in terms of an
environment at a scope,
and think about
what happens here.
So when I read that in or I
evaluate that in Python, it
creates a definition that binds
the name fact to some code,
just all of that stuff
over here plus the name
for the formal parameter, hasn't
done anything with it yet.
And then I'm going to
evaluate print a fact of 4.
Print needs a value, so it has
to get the value of fact of 4,
and we know what that does.
It looks up fact, there it
is, it's procedure definition.
So it creates a new
frame, a new environment,
it calls that procedure,
and inside that frame
the formal parameter for fact
is bound to the value passed in.
So n is bound to 4.
That frame is scoped
by this global frame
meaning it's going to inherit
things in the global frame.
And what does it do?
It says, inside of this frame
evaluate the body of fact.
OK, so it says as n equal to 1?
Nope, it's not, it's 4.
So in that case, go to the
else statement and says,
oh, return n times fact of n
and n as 4, fact of n minus 1
says I need to return
4 times fact of 3.
4 is easy, multiplication
is easy, fact of 3,
ah yes, I look up fact.
Now I'm in this frame,
I don't see fact there,
but I go up to that frame.
There's the definition
for fact, and we're
going to do the rest of
this a little more quickly,
what does that do?
It creates a new
frame called by fact.
And the argument passed
in for n is n minus 1,
that value, right there, of 3.
So 3 is now bound to n.
Same game, evaluate the
body is n equal to 1?
No, so in that case, I'm going
to go to the return statement,
it says return 3
times fact of 2.
And notice it's only
looking at this value of n
because that's the
frame in which I'm in.
It never sees that value of n.
OK, aren't you glad I
didn't do fact of 400?
We've only got two more to
go, but you get the idea.
Same thing, I need
to get fact of 2
is going to call fact
again with n bound to 2.
Relative that evaluates the
body and is not yet equal to 1.
That says I'm going
to the else clause
and return 2 times fact of 1.
I call fact again,
now with n bound to 1,
and, fortunately, now
that clause is true,
and it says return 1.
Whoops, sorry, before I do,
so there's the base case.
And it may seem apparent to you,
but this is important, right?
I'm unwinding this
till I get to something
that can stop the computation.
Now I'm simply going to
gather the computation up,
because it says return 1.
Who asked for it?
Well that call to fact of 1.
So that reduces to
return 2 times 1.
And who called for that?
Fact of 2.
That reduces to return a 3 times
2, which reduces to 4 times
6, which reduces
to printing out 24.
So it unwinds it down to
a base case and it stops.
A couple of observations, notice
how each recursive call creates
its own frame, and
as a consequence,
there's no confusion about
which value of n I'm using.
Also notice, in the other
frames, n was not changed.
We did not mutate it.
So we're literally
creating a local scope
for that recursive call,
which is exactly what we want.
Also notice how there was
a sense of flow of control
in computing fact of something,
that reduces to returning n
times fact of n minus 1, and
that creates a new scope.
And that will simply
keep unwinding
until I get to something
that can return a value
and then I gather all
those frames back up.
So there's a natural
flow of control here.
But most importantly, there's no
confusion about which variable
I'm using when I'm
looking for a value of n.
All right, because this
is often a place where
things get a little confusing,
I want to do one more example.
But let me first
show you side by side
the two different
versions of factorial.
Actually, I have lied slightly,
we didn't show this one earlier
but there's factorial if I
wanted to do it iteratively.
I'd set up some
initial variable to 1,
and then I'd just
run through a loop.
For example, from 1 up to just
below n minus 1, or 1 up to n,
multiplying it and putting
it back into return product.
Which one do you like more?
You can't say neither
you have to pick one.
Show of hands, how many
of you like this one?
Some hesitant ones, how
many prefer this one?
Yeah, that's my view.
I'm biased, but I really
like the recursive one.
It is crisper to look at,
you can see what it's doing.
I'm reducing this
problem to a simpler
version of that problem.
Pick your own
version but I would
argue that the
recursive version is
more intuitive to understand.
From a programmer's
perspective, it's
actually often more
efficient to write,
because I don't have to think
about interior variables.
Depending on the machine,
it may not be as efficient
when you call it because
in the recursive version
I've got it set up,
that set of frames.
And some versions
of these languages
are actually very
efficient about it,
some of them a little less so.
But given the speed
of computers today,
who cares as long as it actually
just does the computation.
Right, one more example,
how do we really
know our recursive code works?
Well, we just did a
simulation but let's
look at it one more way.
The iterative version,
what can I say about it?
Well, I know it's
going to terminate
because b is initially
positive, assuming
I gave it an appropriate value.
It decreases by 1 every
time around this loop,
at some point it has to get
less than 1, it's going to stop.
So I can conclude it's
always going to terminate.
What about the
recursive version?
Well, if I call it with
b equal to one, I'm done.
If I call it with
b greater than one,
again it's going to reduce it
by one on the recursive call,
which means on each recursive
call it's going to reduce
and eventually it
gets down to a place,
assuming I gave it a
positive integer, where
b is equal to one.
So it'll stop, which just good.
What we just did was
we used the great tool
from math, second best
department at MIT.
Wow, I didn't even get any
hisses on that one, John,
all right, and
I'm now in trouble
with the head of
the math department.
So now that I got
your attention,
and yes, all computer
science jokes are bad,
and mine are really
bad, but I'm tenured.
You cannot do a
damn thing about it.
Let's look at mathematical
induction which turns out
to be a tool that lets
us think about programs
in a really nice way.
You haven't seen
this, here's the idea
of mathematical induction.
If I want to prove
a statement, and we
refer to it as being
indexed on the integers.
In other words, it's some
mathematical statement
that runs over integers.
If I want to prove it's true for
all values of those integers,
mathematically I'd do
it by simply proving
it's true for the smallest
value of n typically
n is equal to 0 or 1, and then
I do an interesting thing.
I say I need to prove that
if it's true for an arbitrary
value of n, I'm just going
to prove that it's also then
true for n plus 1.
And if I can do those
two things I can then
conclude for an infinite
number of values of n
it's always true.
Then we'll relate it back
to programming in a second,
but let me show you a
simple example of this, one
that you may have seen.
If I had the integers from 0 up
to n, or even from 1 up to n,
I claim that's the same as
n times n plus 1 over 2.
So 1, 2, 3, that's 6, right.
And that's exactly
right, 3 times 4,
which is divided by 2,
which gives me out 6.
How would I prove this?
Well, by induction?
I need to do the simple
cases if n is equal to 0,
well then this side is just 0.
And that's 0 times 1,
which is 0 divided by true.
So 0 equals 0, it's true.
Now the inductive step.
I'm going to assume
it's true for some k,
I should have picked
n, but for some k,
and then what I need to show
is it's true for k plus 1.
Well, there's the
left hand side,
and I want to show that
this is equal to that.
And I'm going do it by using
exactly this recursive idea,
because what do I know, I know
that this sum, in here, I'm
assuming is true.
And so that says that the left
hand side, the first portion
of it, is just k
times k plus 1 over 2,
that's the definition of the
thing I'm assuming is true.
To that I'm going
to add k plus 1.
Well, you can do
the algebra, right?
That's k plus 1
all times k over 2
plus 1, which is
k plus 2 over 2.
Oh cool, it's exactly that.
Having done that, I
can now conclude this
is true for all values of n.
What does it have to
do with programming?
That's exactly what
we're doing when we think
about recursive code, right?
We're saying, show that
it's true for the base case,
and then what I'm
essentially assuming
is that, if it works for
values smaller than b,
then does the code return
the right answer for b?
And the answer is,
absolutely it does,
and I'm using induction to
deduce that, in fact, my code
does the right thing.
Why am I torturing
you with this?
Because this is the way I want
you to think about recursion.
When I'm going to
break a problem down
into a smaller version
of the same problem,
I can assume that the smaller
version gives the answer.
All I have to do is make sure
that what I combined together
gives me out the right result.
OK, you may be
wondering what I'm
doing with these wonderful
high tech toys down here.
I want to show you another
example of recursion.
So far we've seen simple things
that have just had one base
case, and this is a
mythical story called
The towers of Hanoi and
this story, as I heard it,
is there's a temporal
somewhere in Hanoi
with three tall spikes and 64
jewel-encrusted golden disks
all of a different size.
They all started out on
one spike with the property
that they were ordered from
smallest down to largest.
And there are priests in this
temple who are moving the disks
one at a time, one per
second, and their goal
is to move the entire stack
from one spike to another spike.
And when they do
nirvana is achieved
and we all get a
really great life.
We'll talk separately
about how long
is this going to take because
there's one trick to it.
They can never cover a smaller
disk with a larger disk
as they're doing it, so
they've got a third disk
as a temporary thing.
And I want to show you
how to solve this problem
because you're going to write
code with my help in a second,
or I'm going to write
code with your help
in a second to solve it.
So let's look at it,
so watch carefully,
moving a disk of size one,
well that's pretty easy, right?
Moving a disk of
size two, we'll just
put this one on the spare
one while you move it over
so you don't cover it up.
That's easy.
Moving a disk of
size three, you've
got be a little more careful,
you can't cover up a smaller
one with a larger one, so
you have to really think
about where you're putting it.
It would help with these things
didn't juggle and there you go,
you got it done.
All right, you're watching?
You've got to do four.
To do four, again, you've got to
be really careful not to cover
things up as you do this.
You want to get the bottom
one eventually exposed,
and so are you going to
pull that one over there.
If you do the
pattern really well,
you won't notice if I make
a serious mistake as I'm
doing this, which I just did.
But I'm going to
recover from that
and do it that way to
put this one over here,
and that one goes there, and
if I did this in Harvard Square
I could make money.
There you go, right?
OK, got the solution?
See how to solve it?
Could you write code for this?
Eh, maybe not.
That's on the
quiz, thanks, John,
don't tell them
on the quiz, damn.
All right, I want to claim
though that in fact there's
a beautiful recursive solution.
And here's the way to
think about it recursively.
I want to move a
tower of size n,
I'm going to assume I
can move smaller towers
and then it's really easy.
What do I do, I take a
stack of size n minus 1,
I move it onto the spare one,
I move the bottom one over,
and then I move a
stack of size n minus 1
to there, beautiful,
recursive solution.
And how do I move
the smaller stack?
Just the same way,
I just unwind it,
simple, and, in fact, the
code follows exactly that.
OK, I do a little
[INAUDIBLE] domain up here
to try and get your
attention, but notice
by doing that what did I do?
I asked you to think
about it recursively,
the recursive solution,
when you see it,
is in fact very straightforward,
and there's the code.
Dead trivial, well,
that trivial is unfair,
but it's very simple.
Right?
I simply write something,
so let me describe it,
I need to say how big
of tower am I moving
and I'm going to label the
three stacks a from, a to,
and a spare.
I have a little procedure
that just prints out
the move for me, and
then what's the solution?
If it's just a stack of size
one, just print the move,
take it to from--
from from to to.
Otherwise, move a
tower of size n minus 1
from the from spot to
the spare spot, then move
what's left of tower
size one from to two,
and then take that
thing are stuck on spare
and move it over to
two, and I'm done.
In that code that we handed
out, you'll see this code,
you can run it.
I'm not going to print
it out because, if I did,
you are just going
to say, OK, it
looks like it does the
right kind of thing.
Look at the code, nice
and easy, and that's
what we like you to do when
you're given a problem.
We asked you to think
about recursively.
How do I solve
this with a smaller
version of the same problem?
And then how do I use that
to build the larger solution?
This case is a little different.
You could argue that
this is not really
a recursive call here, it's
just moving the bottom one,
I could have done that directly.
But I've got two recursive
calls in the body here.
I have to move a
smaller stack twice.
We're going to come back
to that in a little bit.
Let me show you one other
example of recursion that
runs a little bit differently.
In this case it's going to
have multiple base cases
and this is another
very old problem,
it's called the
Fibonacci numbers.
It's based on something
from several centuries
ago when a gentleman,
named Leonardo of Pisa,
also known as Fibonacci,
asked the following challenge.
He said, I'm going to put
a newborn pair of rabbits,
one male and one female, into an
enclosure, a pan of some sort.
And the rabbits have the
following properties,
they mate at age one month, so
they take a month to mature.
After a one month
gestation period,
they produce another pair of
rabbits, a male and a female,
and he says I'm going to assume
that the rabbits never die.
So each month mature females are
going to produce another pair.
And his question was, how
many female rabbits are there
at the end of a year, or
two years, or three years?
The idea is, I start off
with two immature rabbits,
after one month
they've matured, which
means after another month, they
will have produced a new pair.
After another month, that mature
pair has produced another pair,
and the immature
pair has matured.
Which means, after
another month,
those two mature pairs are
going to produce offspring,
and that immature
pair has matured.
And you get the idea,
and after several months,
you get to Australia.
You can also see this is going
to be interesting to think
about how do you compute this,
but what I want you to see
is the recursive solution to it.
So how could we capture this?
Well here's another way
of thinking about it,
after the first
month, and I know
we're going to do
this funny thing,
we're going to index it
0, so call it month 0.
There is 1 female
which is immature.
After the second
month, that female
is mature and now pregnant which
means after the third month it
has produced an offspring.
And more generally,
that the n-th month,
after we get past the first
few cases, what do we have?
Any female that was
there two months ago
has produced an offspring.
Because it's taken at
least one month to mature,
if it hasn't
already been mature,
and then it's going to
produce an offspring.
And any female that
was around last month
is still around because
they never die off.
So this is a little different.
This is now the number
of females at month n
is the number of females
T month n minus 1,
plus the number of females
and month n minus 2.
So two recursive calls, but
with different arguments.
Different from towers of Hanoi,
where there were two recursive
calls, but with the
same sized problem.
So now I need two
base cases, one
for when n is equal to 0,
one for when n is equal to 1.
And then I've got
that recursive case,
so there's a nice
little piece of code.
Fibonacci, I'm going to assume
x is an integer greater than
or equal to 0.
I'm going to return
Fibonacci of x.
And you can see now it says,
if either x is equal to 0
or x is equal to 1
I'm going to return 1,
otherwise, reduce it to two
simpler versions of the problem
but with different
arguments, and I add them up.
OK, and if we go look at this,
we can actually run this,
if I can find my code.
Which is right there,
and I'm just going to,
so we can, for example,
check it by saying fib of 0.
I just hit a bug
which I don't see.
Let me try it again.
I'll try it one more
time with fib of 0.
Darn, it's wrong, let me try it.
I've got two different
versions of fib
in here, that's what
I've got going on.
So let me do it again,
let's do fib of 1.
There we go, fib of 2 which
is 2, fib of 3 just three,
and fib of 4 which should
add the previous two, which
gives me 5.
There we go.
Sorry about that, I
had two versions of fib
in my file, which is
why it complained at me.
And which is why
you should always
read the error instructions
because it tells you
what you did wrong.
Let's go on and look at one
more example of doing recursion,
and we're going to
do dictionaries,
and then we're going to
pull it all together.
So far we've been doing
recursion on numerical things,
we can do it on
non-numerical things.
So a nice way of
thinking about this is,
how would I tell if a string
of characters is a palindrome?
Meaning it reads the same
backwards and forwards.
Probably the most
famous palindrome
is attributed to Napoleon
"Able was I ere I saw Elba."
Given that Napoleon
was French, I really
doubt he said "Able
was I ere I saw Elba,"
but it's a great palindrome.
Or another one attributed
to Anne Michaels
"Are we not drawn we few
drawn onward to a new era,"
reads the same
backwards and forwards.
It's fun to think about how
do you create the palindromes.
I want to write
code to solve this.
Again, I want to think
about it recursively,
so here's what I'm going to do.
I'm first going to take
a string of characters,
reduce them all to
lowercase, and strip out
spaces and punctuation.
I just want the characters.
And once I got
that, I want to say,
is that string, that
list of characters
or that collection of characters
as I should say, a palindrome?
And I'm going to think
about it recursively,
and that's actually pretty easy.
If it's either 0 or 1
long, it's a palindrome.
Otherwise you could think
about having an index
at each end of this thing
and sort of counting
into the middle,
but it's much easier
to say take the two at the
end, if they're the same,
then check to see what's left
in the middle is a palindrome,
and if those two properties
are true, I'm done.
And notice what I just did I
nicely reduced a bigger problem
to a slightly smaller problem.
It's exactly what I want to do.
OK?
So it says to check is
this, I'm going to reduce it
to just the string
of characters,
and then I'm going to check if
that's a palindrome by pulling
those two off and checking
to see they're the same,
and then checking to see if the
middle is itself a palindrome.
How would I write it?
I'm going to create a procedure
up here, isPalindrome.
I'm going to have inside of it
two internal procedures that
do the work for me.
The first one is simply
going to reduce this
to all lowercase with no spaces.
And notice what I can do because
s is a string of characters.
I can use the built in string
method lower, so there's
that dot notation, s.lower.
It says. apply the
method lower to a string.
I need an open and close
per end to actually call
that procedure, and
that will mutate
s to just be all lowercase.
And then I'm going
to run a little loop,
I'll set up answer or ans
to be an empty string,
and then, for everything
inside that mutated string,
I'll simply say, if it's inside
this string, if it's a letter,
add it into answer.
If it's a space or comma or
something else I'll ignore it,
and when I'm done
just return answer,
strips it down to lowercase.
And then I'm going to pass that
into isPal which simply says,
if this is either
0 or 1 long, it's
a palindrome, returned true.
Otherwise, check to see that
the first and last element
of the string are
the same, notice
the indexing to get
into the last element,
and similarly just
slice into the string,
ignoring the first and
last element, and ask
is that a palindrome.
And then just call it,
and that will do it.
And again there's a nice example
of that in the code I'm not
going to run it, I'll let
you just go look at it,
but it will actually pull
out something that checks,
is this a palindrome.
Notice again, what
I'm doing here.
I'm doing divide-and-conquer.
I'm taking a problem reducing
it, I keep saying this,
to a simpler version
of the same problem.
Keep unwinding it
till I get down
to something I can
solve directly,
my base case and I'm done.
And that's really
the heart of thinking
about recursive
solutions to problems.
I would hope that one of
the things I remember,
besides my really
lousy patter up here,
is the idea of Towers of
Hanoi, because to me it's
one of the nicest
examples of a problem that
would be hard to
solve iteratively,
but when you see the
recursive solution is
pretty straightforward.
Keep that in mind as you
think about doing recursion.
OK, let's switch
gears, and let's
talk very briefly about
another kind of data type
called a dictionary.
And the idea of a
dictionary I'm going
to motivate with
a simple example.
There's a quiz coming
up on Thursday.
I know you don't
want to hear that,
but there is, which means we're
going to be recording grades.
And so imagine I wanted to
build a little database just
to keep track of
grades of students.
So one of the ways
I could do it,
I could create a list with
the names of the students,
I could create another
list with their grades,
and a third list with the
actual subject or course
from which they got that great.
I keep a separate list
for each one of them,
keep them of the same
length, and in essence,
what I'm doing here is
I'm storing information
at the same index in each list.
So Ana, who's going to have to
take the class again, gets a B,
John, who's created the class,
gets an A plus, Sorry Ana,
John's had a longer time at it.
All right, bad jokes
aside, what I'm doing
is I can imagine
just creating lists.
I could create lists of
lists, but a simple way
is to do lists where
basically at each index
I've got associated information.
It's a simple way
to deal with it.
Getting a grade out takes
a little bit of work
because if I want to
get the grade associated
with a particular
student, what would I do?
I would go into the name list
and use the method index, which
you've seen before, again
notice the dot notation
it says, this is a list,
use the index method,
call it on student, and
whatever the value of student
is, it will find
that in the list,
return the index at
that point, and then I
can use that to go in and
get the grade in the course
and return something out.
Simple way to do it but
a little ugly, right,
because among other
things, I've got things
stored in different
places in the list.
I've got to think about if
I'm going to add something
to the list I've got to put them
in the same spot in the list.
I've got to remember to
always index using integers
which is what we know how to
do with lists, at least so far.
It would be nice if I had
a better way to do it,
and that's exactly
what a dictionary
is going to provide for me.
So rather than
indexing on integers
I'd like to index directly
on the item of interest.
I'd like to say
where's Ana's record
and find that in
one data structure.
And so, whereas a list
is indexed by integers,
and has elements associated
with it, a dictionary is going
to combine a key, or if you
like, a name of some sort,
with an actual value.
And we're going to
index just by the name
or the label as we go into it.
So let me show
you some examples.
First of all, to create a
dictionary I use curly braces,
open closed curly brace,
so an empty dictionary
would be simply that call.
If I want to create
an actual dictionary,
before I insert
things into it, I
use a little bit of
a funky notation.
It is a key or a label,
a colon, and then
a value, in this
case the string Ana
and the string b, followed
by a comma which separates it
from the next pairing
of a key and a label,
or a key and a value, and so on.
So if I do this what it
does in my dictionary
is it creates pairings of
those labels with the values
I associated with them.
OK, these are pretty
simple, but in fact, there's
lots of nice things
we can do with it.
So once we've got them indexing
now is similar to a list
but not done by a number,
it's done by value.
So if that's my key, I can
say, what's John's grade,
notice the call, it's grades,
which is in my dictionary,
open close square brackets,
with the label John.
And what it does, it goes in and
finds that in the dictionary,
returns the value
associated with it.
If I ask for something
not in the dictionary,
it's going to give
me a key error.
Other things we can
do with dictionaries,
we can add entries just
like we would do with lists.
Grades as a dictionary, in open
and closed square brackets,
I put in a new
label and a value,
and that adds that
to the dictionary.
I can test if something's in
the dictionary by simply saying,
is this label in
grades, and it simply
checks all of the labels or
the keys for the dictionary
to see if it's there, and
if it's not returns false.
I can remove entries, del,
something we've seen before,
a very generic thing.
It will delete something,
and in this case,
it says, in the
dictionary grades,
find the entry associated
with that key, sorry, Ana,
you're about to be
flushed, remove it.
She's only getting a b in
the class and she teaches it.
We've got to do something
about this, right?
So I can add things,
I can delete things,
I can test if things are there.
Let me show you a
couple of other things
about dictionaries.
I can ask for all of the
keys in the dictionary.
Notice the format, there is
that dot notation, grades
as a dictionary, it says, use
the keys method associated
with this data
structure dictionaries.
Open close actually
calls it, and it gives me
back a collection of all the
keys in some arbitrary order.
I'm going to use
a funny term here
which I'm not certain
we've seen so far.
It returns something we call
an iterable, it's like range.
Think of it as giving us back
the equivalent of a list,
it's not actually
a list, but it's
something we can walk down.
Which is exactly why I
can then say, is something
in a dictionary, because it
returns this set of keys,
and I can test to see
something's in there.
I can similarly get
all of the values
if I wanted to look at them,
giving us out two iterables.
Here are the key things to keep
in mind about dictionaries.
The values can be anything,
any type, mutable, immutable.
They could be duplicates.
That'd actually makes sense,
I could have the same value
associated, for example,
the same grade associated
with different people,
that's perfectly fine.
The values could be lists, they
could be other data structures,
they could even be
other dictionaries.
They can be anything,
which is great.
The keys, the first part of it
are a little more structure.
They need to be unique.
Well duh, that make sense.
If I have that same key in
two places in the dictionary,
when I go to look
it up, how am I
going to know which one I want?
So it needs to be
unique, and they also
need to be immutable,
which also makes sense.
If I'm storing something
in a key in the dictionary,
and I can go and change
the value of the key,
how am I going to remember
what I was looking for?
So they can only be things like
ints, floats, strings, tuples,
Booleans.
I don't recommend using
floats because you need
to make sure it's
exactly the same float
and that's sometimes a
little bit challenging,
but nonetheless, you can have
any immutable type as your key.
And notice that there's no
order to the keys or the values.
They are simply stored
arbitrarily by the Python
as it puts them in.
So if I compare these two, lists
or ordered sequences indexed
by integers, I look them
up by integer index,
and the indices have to have
an order as a consequence.
Dictionaries are this
nice generalization,
arbitrarily match
keys to values.
I simply look up one
item by looking up things
under the appropriate key.
All I require is that the
keys have to be immutable.
OK, I want to do
two last things I've
got seven minutes to go here.
I want to show you an example
of using dictionaries,
and I'm going to do this
with a little bit more
interesting, I hope, example.
I want to analyze song lyrics.
Now I'm going to show
you, you can already
tell the difference between
my age and Ana's age.
She used Taylor Swift
and Justin Bieber.
I'm going to use The Beatles.
That's more my generation.
Most of you have never
heard of The Beatles
unless you watched
Shining Time Station where
you saw Ringo Starr, right?
OK, what I'm going
to do is, I want
to write a little
set of procedures
that record the frequencies
of words in a song lyric.
So I'm going to match strings,
or words, to integers.
How many times did that word
appear in the song lyric?
And then I want to ask,
can I easily figure out
which words occur most
often, and how many times.
Then I'm going to
gather them together
to see what are the most
common words in here.
And I'm going to do that where
I'm going to let a user say,
I want every word that appears
more than some number of times.
It's a simple
example, but I want
you to see how a mutation
of the dictionary
gives you a really powerful
tool for solving this problem.
So let's write the
code to do that.
It's also in the
handout, here we go.
Lyrics to frequency's, lyrics is
just a list of words, strings.
So I'm going to set up
an empty dictionary,
there's that open
close curly brace,
and here's what I want to do.
I'm going to walk through
all the words in lyrics.
You've seen this
before, this is looping
over every word in lyrics.
Ah, notice what I'm going to do.
I'm going to simply say-- so
the first part is, I can easily
iterate over the list,
--but now I'm going to say,
if the word is in
the dictionary,
and because the
dictionary is iterable,
it's simply going to give
me back all of the keys,
it's simply going to
say, in this case,
if it's in the dictionary,
it's already there,
I've got some value
associated with it,
get the value out, add
1 to it, put it back in.
If it's not already
in the dictionary,
this is the first time
I've seen it, just store it
into the dictionary.
And when I'm done just
return the dictionary.
OK?
So I'm going to, if I can do
this right with my Python,
show you an example of this.
I have put in one of the
great classic Beatles songs,
you might recognize
it right there.
Mostly because it's got a whole
lot of repetitions of things.
So she loves you yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, actually they sing
it better than I just
did it sarcastically.
Sorry about that, but I
got she loves you there,
and here's my code up
here, lyrics to frequency.
So let's see what
happens if we call it.
And we say lyrics to
frequencies she loves you.
And it would help
if I can type, all
right, we'll try it
one more time, lyrics
to frequency's, she loves you.
Cool, this gave me
back a dictionary,
you can see the curly
braces, and there
are all the words that appear
in there and the number of times
that they appear.
What's the order?
You don't care.
You don't know.
What we want to do
is to think about
how can we analyze
this, so let's go back
and look at the
last piece of this.
Which is, OK, I can convert
lyrics to frequencies.
So here's the next thing
I want to do, how do I
find the most common words?
Well, here's what
I'm going to do,
frequencies is the
dictionary, something
that I just pulled out.
So I can use the
values method on it
which returns and iterable,
as I said earlier,
again notice the open close
because I got to call it.
That gives me back
an iterable that
has all of the frequencies
inside of there,
because it's an iterable,
I can use max on it,
and it will take that
editable and give me back
the biggest value.
I'm going to call that
best, I'm going to set up
words to be an empty
list, and then I'm
just going to walk
through all of the entries
in the dictionary saying,
if the value at that entry
is equal to best add
that entry into words,
just append it onto
the end of the list.
And when I'm done
all of that loop,
I'm just going to return a
tuple of both the collections
of words that period
that many times
and how often they appeared.
I'm going to show you
an example in a second,
but notice I'm simply using the
properties of the dictionary.
The last thing I want
to do then is say,
I want to see how
often the words appear.
So I'm going to give it a
dictionary and a minimum number
of times.
And here I'm going to set
result up to be an empty list,
I'm going to create
a flag called false,
it's going to keep
track of when I'm done.
And as long as I'm
not yet done, I'll
call that previous
procedure that's
going to give me back
the most common words
and how often they appeared.
I check and remember
it was a tuple,
how often do they appear, if
it's bigger than the thing
I'm looking for, I'll
add that into my result.
And then the best
part is, I'm now
going to walk
through all the words
that appeared that many
times, and just delete them
from the dictionary.
I can mutate the dictionary.
And by doing that, I can go
back around and do this again,
and it will pull out how
many times has this appeared
and keep doing it.
When I can go all
the way through that,
if I can't find any
more, I'll set the flag
to true which means it
will drop out of here
and return the result. I'm going
to let you run this yourself,
if you do that, you'll
find that it comes up with,
not surprisingly, I think
yeah is the most common one
and she loves you, followed
by loves and a few others.
What I want you to see here
is how the dictionary captured
the pieces we wanted to.
Very last one,
there's Fibonacci,
as we called it before.
It's actually
incredibly inefficient,
because if I call it, I
have to do all the sub
calls until I get down to
the base case, which is OK.
But notice, every
other thing I do here,
I've actually
computed those values.
I'm wasting measures,
or wasting time,
it's not so bad with fib of
5, but if this is fib of 20,
almost everything on the
right hand side of this tree
I've already computed once.
That means fibs
very inefficient.
I can improve it by using a
dictionary, very handy tool.
I'm going to call fib not
only with a value of n,
but a dictionary
which initially I'm
going to initialized
to the base cases.
And notice what I do, I'm
going to say if I've already
computed this, just return
the value in the dictionary.
If I haven't, go ahead
and do the computation,
store it in the
dictionary at that point,
and return the answer.
Different way of
thinking about it,
and the reason this is really
nice is a method called
memoization, is if
I call fib of 34
the standard way it takes 11
million plus recursive calls
to get the answer out.
It takes a long time.
I've given you some
code for it, you
can try it and see
how long it takes.
Using the dictionary to keep
track of intermediate values,
65 calls.
And if you try it, you'll
see the difference in speed
as you run this.
So dictionaries
are valuable, not
only for just storing
away data, they're
valuable on procedure calls when
those intermediate values are
not going to change.
What you're going to
see as we go along
is we're going to use exactly
these ideas, using dictionaries
to capture information, but
especially using recursion
to break bigger problems
down into smaller
versions of the same problem,
to use that as a tool
for solving what turn out
to be really complex things.
And with that, we'll
see you next time.